erst im letzten jahr wurde unser
nächster exoplaneten entdeckt proxima
centauri b so viel lichtjahre entfernt
und schon jetzt wissen wir mehr über ihn
also wie viele andere exoplaneten
forscher haben nämlich sein klima
simuliert und das ergebnis ist
vielversprechend egal welches szenario
die wissenschaftler auch anwenden
proxima centauri bever potenziell
lebensfreundlich finden wir also
außerirdisches schon auf unseren
nächsten nachbarn jetzt wirklich zum
seite sind herzlich willkommen
noch vor 30 jahren hatten die menschen
keinerlei ahnung von exoplaneten wir
wussten einfach nicht ob es da draußen
nur schwärme gibt die konnten wir
nämlich beobachten oder weitere planeten
wegen unserem sonnensystem
wobei schon in den 80er jahren des
letzten jahrhunderts die ersten
exoplaneten beobachtet wurden aber
falsch klassifiziert oder wieder
verworfen worden erst 1992 wurden
zuverlässig die ersten exoplaneten
identität und bei denen werden immer
mehr exoplaneten entdeckt inzwischen
findet mit stand von heute 3611
inzwischen ist klar wie das universum
aufgebaut ist überall gibt sonnensysteme
wie unseres und überall kreisen planeten
um das zentralgestirn zumindest ist das
sehr sehr oft der fall bei proxima
centauri wurde schon 2013 einen
exoplaneten dabei erfragen wechseln
konnte er bestätigt werden der stern und
weniger chrysler so proxima centauri
nämlich ein wenig und diese und doch ist
nur mit einem planeten erklärbar proxima
centauri bks in der habitablen zone um
das zentralgestirn womit möglich ist
dass es dort außerirdische lebensformen
gesetzt haben wissenschaftler das
mögliche klima auf dem planeten
simuliert und das ergebnis in allen
szenarien gibt es lebensfreundliche
bedingungen auf proxima centauri b der
planet bietet ein erstaunlich stabiles
klima system und die temperaturen sind
perfekt für leben wie wir hier auf der
erde kennen und das obwohl proxima
centauri 20 mal dichter um seinen stern
kreist als wir hier um die sonne
allerdings ist der stern deutlich kühler
als sie wollen wir uns auch kleiner rief
ein roter zwerg so seine sterne trotzdem
würde auf dem planeten wie die sonne
hier auf der erde weiß scheint er wäre
aber scheinbar dreimal größer als die
sonne und je nach zusammensetzung der
atmosphäre und die umlaufbahn um den
stern herrschen auch proxima centauri b
aber immer lebensfreundliche bedingungen
würde er zum beispiel um die eigene
achse rotieren hätten wir auf der
oberfläche temperaturen von knapp über
null hätte er eine gebundene rotation
also wäre immer eine seite seinen stern
zugewandt was wahrscheinlich ist wie bei
unserer mode während auf diese weise bis
zu rund 30 grad
viel wird und je nachdem ob der planet
auf einer nicht ganz runden bahn um
proxima centauri könnten die bedingungen
noch besser sein
jetzt kommt es drauf an wie leben im
weltall entsteht wenn es so ist das
leben hier auf der erde durch die
verkettung mehrerer glücklicher umstände
entstanden ist dann sieht es eher
schlecht aus für proxima centauri aber
wenn es wirklich so ist dass ihnen die
grundform des lebens also zum beispiel
aminosäuren auf die erde gebracht haben
quasi als fan spermien dann ist die
frage dringend das ist dort leben gibt
wissenschaftler versuchen so zu erklären
warum das leben hier auf der erde so
schnell entstanden ist oder es ist so
dass diese bausteine quasi unter
lebensfreundliche bedingungen immer sehr
schnell entstehen und so zwangsläufig
zur entstehung von leben führen in
beiden fällen würde es bedeuten dass es
dort oder diesen bedingungen
zwangsläufig leben geben muss ich
persönlich wie immer mehr davon
überzeugt dass wir hier kein einmaliger
zufalls alles in welt alles scheint
darauf hinzudeuten dass es überall leben
gibt das ist überall optimale
bedingungen zu leben gibt so viele
exoplaneten die wir inzwischen in
habitablen also lebensfreundlichen zone
gefunden haben und es gibt sie überall
komplexe organische moleküle wurden
selbst in pro planetaren scheiden also
dem gestein scheiben vor der entstehung
von planeten rund um einen jungen stern
entdeckt
das hätte drei konsequenzen erstens
überall entsteht unser lebensfreundliche
bedingungen auch leben
zweitens entsteht immer sehr schnell
weil die bausteine schon da sind oder
eben durch akteure willkommen und
drittens und das ist jetzt vielleicht
ein bisschen verwegen dem gleich alten
vektoren des universums ist das leben
auch immer ähnlich weit entwickelt weil
es sich unter bestimmten bedingungen
immer ähnlich entwickelt das ist jetzt
wirklich mein eigenes gesang experiment
wenn alles im universum gleich ist
sterne schwarze löcher aktiven kometen
planeten warum es das leben denn dann
nicht auch überall gleich könnte es sein
dass überall wesen mit beinen mit armen
und beinen mit den tag mit flossen
entstehen weil das die optimalen
biologischen merkmale sind um auf
planeten zu überleben ich bin sehr
gespannt
ob wie es noch erleben werden wenn es
dazu erkenntnisse gibt vielleicht wenn
wir den warp antrieb erfunden haben die
erste reise dürfte zu proxima centauri
begehen wenn es etwas neues zu proxima
centauri begibt oder zum antrieb erfahrt
ihr es natürlich hier dafür mir hier ein
abo aufs auge drücken
und wenn er mir dann noch einen dann
verpasst ihr auch garantiert kein video
hier geht es weiter mit
finden wir noch dieses jahr
außerirdische radioteleskope werden neu
ausgerichtet einfach draufklicken da
geht weiteren ansonsten bleibt dran